yes
[Music]
[Applause]
this afternoon's vote is unprecedented
but so was the action taken to expel
members of the legislature voters in
District 52 elected Justin Jones to be
their voice at the state house and that
voice was taken away this past week so
let's give them their voice back and I'd
call on this body to vote unanimously
right now to do just that
[Music]
okay
you can see
[Music]
the people of Tennessee I stand with you
we will continue to be your voice here
and no exposure no attempt to silence us
will stop us but only Galvanize and
strengthen our movement and we continue
to show up in the people's house power
to the people
[Music]
thank you